Hello, everybody. My name is Chris
and I'm here on Psych2Go to talk to you guys about multitasking and why you really shouldn't do it.
I'm going to tell you straight out, you
can't multitask. At all. your brain cannot handle it and it has to do with your short-term memory.
Your short-term memory, also known as your working memory
stores visual and verbal information
for a short period of time anywhere from 30 to 60 seconds with a limited capacity.
The working theory on our working memory is
7 plus or minus 2. In other words,
our short-term memory can hold anywhere from 5 items to 9 items at any given time. And when you're multitasking you're definitely
putting in more than 5 or 9 items into your short-term memory, thus overloading your brain with Data. And
when your brain is overloaded with data, some of that data doesn't make it into your short-term memory,
and if it doesn't make it into a short-term memory, it's not going to make it into your long-term memory,
and you're not going to remember it.
In other words, multitasking doesn't make you more efficient or a
time-saver. In fact it makes you less efficient and waste more time.
And that about wraps is video up, guys! If you guys want to see more content like this,
please go to site to Psych2Go.net.
Please remember to follow our tumblr page at Psych2Go.tumblr.net, and please remember to subscribe
to our YouTube channel! Right here
we'll be making videos like this based off of articles from Psych2Go.net and
if you guys like this video, remember to give it a big thumbs up, and that's about all the time I have.
See you guys next time. Bye!